good day everybody and welcome
i'm jack van horn from the university of
virginia and please allow me to welcome
you to this edition
of our 2020 2021 foundations of
biomedical data science seminar series
it's my honor and privilege to welcome
our speaker today dr tor wager
diana l taylor distinguished professor
of neuroscience at dartmouth college
in hanover new hampshire his uh
completed a
bachelor of arts degree in music from
1992 to
and completed his phd in psychology in
2003
from the university of michigan he has
held faculty positions
at columbia university at the university
of colorado in boulder and since
2019 has been at dartmouth college
up in new england under the direction of
professor wager the cognitive and
effective neuroscience lab studies the
neuropsychology
and neurophysiology of the effective
processes involved in pain
emotion stress and empathy and how
they're shaped by cognitive and social
influences
his lab is particularly interested in
how thoughts beliefs and expectations
affect the brain and the body and they
use a range of techniques including
psychophysiology
electroencephalography pharmacology as
well as neuroimaging
to understand those processes relevant
to the brain and data science
his lab is also dedicated to the
development of new computational models
for the analysis and
synthesis of neural imaging data
especially fmri
and to work to promote the open sharing
of tools and scientific data
additionally dr wager is also no
stranger to providing online educational
lectures
on neuroscientific data analytic
approaches
he has many honors and he is funded
through
currently through a number of nih r01s
he has had funding from the national
science foundation the army research
institute templeton foundation
and several other grand warden bodies
again numerous awards from the national
science foundation
um the american psychonomic society
amongst others and he also has two
patents that he is the
holder of on a variety of research
projects
um his topic today is going to be the
neural imaging of pain and affect
generalizable models for prediction and
explanation and as always we are
streaming
this lecture live and for recording via
youtube and if you are watching on
youtube thank you so much for joining us
also our specially selected 2020-2021
biomedical data science innovation lab
participants
are encouraged to submit any questions
for dr wager via the chat feature in
their zoom sessions
i will synthesize these questions and
ask them on your behalf during the last
10 minutes or so of dr wager's lecture
and with that welcome tour we are
looking very much forward to your
lecture
great thank you so much for inviting me
it's really a pleasure to be here and
to be able to share some of our work
with you and some ideas
i'm going to go back to the main reason
to do
neuroimaging the first place which is
that neuroimaging
the promise is that it'll play a unique
role in this chain from molecules to
cells to systems
to human behavior and disease
and since the start of neuroimaging
research in humans about 20 years ago i
think we all thought that this is going
to take off and change the world
i think it is changing the world but
it's also taken longer than
expected and there have been a few bumps
along the way
uh many of those bumps have made it into
media and
in exaggerated ways uh so here in this
in this uh
cover article from new scientists a few
years ago uh
it says the vast majority of brain
research is now drowning in
uncertainty uh and there have been a
number of critiques that have been
important
including critiques of effect sizes and
how we estimate them
critiques of power and sample size
in narrow imaging critiques about our
reproducibility and how we make
inferences about different pieces of
the brain especially here around heavy
threshold
and most recently this year critiques
about reliability
of task fmri measures and as you see at
the bottom
there since this is from 2010 max
coldheart coldheart
but but the the history of these kinds
of critiques about what neuroimaging can
tell us about the mind
go way back to the very earliest imaging
studies
as well and if you boil these critiques
down
there of the following things which i i
was just talking about you have effect
size power and false positives
reliability
inferences about the mind and and
influences about
translation they do extend these
critiques beyond
brain imaging itself uh so here's
an example of an important critique of
gene by environment interactions in the
field of genetics is
was really very early in jumping on this
idea that we have
you know too many false positives which
stem from sort human tests
and uh you know discover very broad
critiques of course that many of us know
about
why most published research findings are
false and neuroimaging has even been
compared with phrenology
which as i'll show you is an
uncharitable comparison
because there's no situation under which
phrenology can yield
externally valid predictions and
inferences about
the mind or personality or individual
differences
but with neuroimaging there is a lot of
promise
that we can indeed uh construct measures
of test states
of mental states and even clinical uh
phenomena
that are externally valid and
reproducible and reliable
but the central claim
i'll make in this paper is to suggest to
you that
we've been doing it wrong we need a
paradigm shift
and that paradigm shift is from
constructing maps
which are local estimates of different
bits of brain and what which bits of the
brain is doing
to integrated models which are
uh a model in general is a system where
you specify what the parts of the system
are and how they interact with one
another
and applied to brain imaging the model
will be
uh specifying how different pieces of
the brain and different brain measures
are combined together and interact to
predict an outcome that we care about
clinically or behaviorally or in terms
of performance
and central to this idea is that if we
can construct stable models in the brain
of which brain features or measures
uh where we're integrating in which way
then that leads us to strong and
falsifiable predictions
much of the kind that einstein for
example made
based on his theories back in 1915 which
were tested years later by edington so
einstein predicted that
that starlight would the light from the
sun would lit with lens
around the moon when um during the
eclipse and
that test of this the first empirical
test of this was really what
put einstein and relativity on the map
so that's a goal for us and i'll also
claim that
we need a biomarker development
framework or a model development
framework
where we iteratively optimize uh brain
patterns and features
um we construct models and markers of
outcomes that we care about
we validate those prospectively and test
their generalizability specificity and
other measurement properties
we characterize their robustness their
boundary conditions what do they
respond to and not respond to under
which conditions do they work
and not work and uh to the degree that
we have
valid and validated models then we can
we can test them
and we can start to use them to
understand what the structure of the
mind is like
as represented at least in the brain um
so central this idea is the idea of
contract validation understanding what
something measures
and this takes a lot of work this is one
of the reasons that we're really at very
early stages
of developing these models as a
counterpoint to some of the critiques
i'll point you to this is a review that
we wrote a few years ago now
uh it's it's a snapshot of translational
studies
and here we had almost 500 studies and
you know more than 500 predictive maps
that all
use machine learning or pattern
recognition techniques to do various
things in various disorders
and you can see the breakdown across
disorders here uh there's more things
coming out every day this is a rapidly
growing field
and on the right what you can see is in
all these different areas
of mental and brain health there are
models that uh that that seem to in this
case
predict you know who's got a disorder
versus controls
with high accuracy and on the y-axis you
see the accuracy there
close to 100 each of these dots is a
study and the size of the circle
represents the sample size and the
larger circles
are large studies even up to and over a
thousand participants
so we've come a long way and these kinds
of models
are not perfect but they're being
combined with increasingly large data
sets
through massive data sharing and data
and model sharing efforts and that's
going to be a theme of today's talk as
well
so this is accuracy of the uk biobank
you go from a small study
to a big study to now the uk vital bank
study is the largest
uh study i believe currently being
collected with 100 000
individuals so we're really moving
towards population neuroscience
and here's a small table of a number of
really
important large-scale efforts where
data are being collected and shared with
communities to analyze them
and uh and discover new things um one
example
is uh this you know recent
effort by vince calhoun's group uh they
call it
neural mark and um one of the important
features of this
is that it's a system of um classifiers
based on independent component analysis
they fed in lots of data from several of
these large samples
so they have 12 000 you know people in
this
in this paper overall and they're
predicting on things like
a diagnostic category
[Music]
all right so very much different from
uh phrenology of old i'm going to turn
to an example from
our lab and use that to illustrate the
biomarker
development and testing process and what
it can do for us
so traditional brain mapping is really
uh the the assessment or the conduction
of a number of separate tests
so we'll look at a little bit of the
brain the voxel and say
well okay which psychological uh
stimuli or or test states are predicting
activity in that box
and then you do it again for the next
box and the next one and the next one
for a hundred thousand boxes or
something
uh and what you get is a map a
collection of
different local effects but it does
little to help you understand
how it works or even whether you could
predict a new instance
of that test state a predictive model
flips the equation around and so now
multiple brain voxels or other features
they could be connectivity features
or graph you know topological measures
or anything else
but the idea here where i'm going to
illustrate with uh with
simple linear patterns across voxels
is that is that these brain measures are
allowed to combine together to jointly
project
the outcome and once you have developed
a predictive model
you can test it prospectively in various
ways so you beat on it
test its properties we can apply the
models that i'm going to share with you
to new samples new individuals
with from different scanners and
different populations
and you can use those to predict
continuous outcomes
we'll talk about predicting how much
pain are you feeling now
or categorical outcomes you know are you
a patient or a control
are you unconscious or conscious uh are
you feeling pain or are you not feeling
pain
and so forth so a simple version of how
this looks
schematically and i think that there are
many algorithms for doing this i think
the algorithms are interesting but
but not necessarily the key thing and
not the focus here
that we'll take a training sample we'll
take a group of individuals
and here we're going to apply multiple
levels of painful stimuli from fairly
painful
for that person to about as painful as
they can tolerate so there's four levels
per person
and then we're going to use essentially
a giant regression model
to identify a linear pattern that gives
us
the best weights for combining brain
regions to predict
pain experience so that's what i'm going
to call a signature map
which is a precisely specified pattern
that we can validate
and the the where sort of machine
learning comes into it
is how good that model is depends on how
you construct that
the algorithm and how you sample data so
um
you know two key ideas that many of you
know about are
cross validation to to develop estimates
and some techniques for stabilizing
those models
so that you don't get a bunch of garbage
essentially so you have sort of stable
interpretable maps i'll come back to
that more again
so one of the first models we developed
was called the neurologic pain signature
because
we want a name that that we can reuse
and refer to and the journal editor
suggested it and we didn't want to
offend the journal editor so that name's
back and
this pain predictive pattern includes
many areas that we know and love in pain
research and beyond
and the key thing here is that there is
a precisely specified
pattern within each region and we're
integrating across regions
and all of those areas are really
sensible in terms of mapping onto
invasive research in humans and animals
and
so there's a there's backing from
neuroscience studies
we can do many things with this model
then on on
new data applied to different individual
subjects
so we can take a series like this where
people get a threat cue
and then a painful warm stimulus and
then they recall pain so we have three
different sort of phases of the trial
and we can apply the pain signature to
calculate
a single response for every
trial or event and so we can take those
trials like this
for a person we can use those to
predict how much pain they're feeling so
now we're looking at the pain related
responses
and you can see this is one
representative subject um
the the actual sort of sequence of
temperatures that they have here and
then the predicted sequence
um here you can see uh the
model trained to predict how much pain a
person is feeling each line is a person
and each dot is an average over several
trials within that
that individual person of different
intensities
and we can take those and we can resort
those trials into
the different uh types of events and we
can do then a test
again in in new uh individuals so it's
unbiased
which is more painful you know uh is it
the heat
the anticipation period or the pain
recall period and we can then
and what you see here is that you know
the the
um this pain signature i just showed you
responds with increasing stimulus
intensity when it's
you're actually getting heat at the
moment it does not respond at all to
anticipation or pain we call
judging pain afterwards and that's been
consistent across
many studies now in our group and others
so here
uh in a out of subject classification we
can take a new person
and we're 100 accurate in the sample you
know at deciding which of the pain
uh conditions
um then we can apply this to new test
data where we take
something from a person from a different
scanner we apply that signature
and what that means is we just take the
pattern weights as a template
take a data image coming in and we can
calculate the dot product
and there's some other metrics as well
but that's the main one that we focused
on
and that boils the map down into a
single
value which in this case is the
predicted way the pattern response
or pattern expression and now we can see
here
that um if we apply the nps to this new
study of multiple
stimulus intensities uh it responds with
an increasing function just like
pain itself actually does and we can
tell
which is more painful out of conditions
where people get a
48 degree or 47 degree stimulus for
example
with 100 accuracy per person in a forced
choice test
here's another application to a new
subject from a different scanner
so they get 46 47 48 degree noxious heat
low medium and high
and we can each line as a subject and
then we can turn that into a classifier
that's a continuous readout we turn it
into a classifier by saying
which is more painful the higher the low
and if we were to make a guess
for each person in this sample we would
get it right about 96
of the time that's been a benchmark
across studies for this particular
pattern
so this is really a way forward
you know what are some of the advantages
well for one thing
we've reduced the analysis flexibility i
fixed the pattern
and so instead of testing a hundred
thousand things and trying to correct
the multiple comparisons across them
if i'm trying to validate that signature
response
i just do one test and that leads to
strong inference or falsifiable tests
number two it capitalizes on distributed
brain codes and that can increase
effect sizes and reliability
dramatically relative to looking at
the standard paradigm of single regions
or single
boxes uh and third it opens the way for
model sharing
so i can share this with you i'll come
back to this at the end
um and you can test it for yourself and
you can share data with us
if you want to and we can test it and
that helps us to
establish what its boundary conditions
are what is this thing actually tracking
uh and validate uh uh the construct that
it's actually
measuring so here's a little bit about
reliability one of the
meta-analyses that just came out this
year is really a broad critique of past
fmri as being unreliable uh and perhaps
too unreliable for um to
to serve as biomarkers that's sort of a
claim
um and this uh is a response that was
just accepted in psychological science
so it's coming out soon
and what you see here is the reliability
of
pain ratings themselves across eight
studies aged dots of study
uh which are excellent um uh and
you see the reliability of the nps pain
signature
which is also in the excellent range uh
and here we actually have quite strong
reliability for even some individual
regions responding to pain like the
anterior cingulate insula
which is not always the case actually
but but the distributed pattern is quite
reliable
here are some other examples this is
from one on the left is from p generous
lab a large
population health study uh predicting
essentially physiological measures of
cardiovascular disease risk
and they have a uh a short-term test
root test reliability uh here that's
also in the excellent range
and you can see there each dot is a
person and what's happening here is it's
the first half of the the session and
the second half
so it's a short-term test re-test i'm
happy to talk more about the liability
as well
on the right you see two examples of
clinical classification
so uh the top one comes from really a a
landmark
effort by drysdale and colleagues in
connor liston's lab
that develops biotypes for depression
and in
independent samples they can classify
depressed versus control patients with
high accuracy
that's an external uh validation and
they can they can uh identify which of
those biotypes they are
accurately and on the bottom you see a
test state classification
faces versus places so um it's just a
demonstration that
using the same data from the human uh
the hcp human connectome project
that later now used in their in their
analysis
we can actually identify a distributed
pattern that is
highly reliable at identifying what
state
people are in
and as i said the critiques of
of science recently have gone really
beyond uh
fmri and and neuroscience even
themselves
to all kinds of fields and psychology
has been one of the the main ones
um and so what you see here is sort of
one of the landmark papers
in this area and they point out that
analysis flexibility is a huge problem
researchers have many many decisions to
make
decisions about whether to stop blocking
data or collect more
which outliers are the other points to
exclude which measures to analyze which
covariates to use
which types of pre-processing and
modeling and correction
uh i'm a fan for example of josh carp's
paper where there's thousands and
thousands of different ways to analyze
the same data set
and they give you different answers
right and of course which findings count
as support for a hypothesis that i'm
going to
come back to in a second so the term you
know p
hacking sums up a lot of things
it sums up this idea of you know
iteratively making analysis decisions
uh or changing your interpretation in
order to
increase the likelihood of finding
something that you want to
see consciously or unconsciously so this
is a powerful force
um and i'm just going to show you a
recent paper that we did with uh
juani wu my former student who's now a
professor at skku
in south korea and um and
this really illustrates the idea
that analysis flexibility in the
standard brain mapping
uh paradigm is a killer so here
you've got uh this is a really real data
example from social rejection
study that we did a few years ago and
what you see is
you know a pattern of activity in
response to
being rejected by another person and so
typically you might conclude the
anterior cingulate cortex is activated
there's a hot spot it survives
correction for multiple comparisons
but if you look at the unthresholded
patterns next to it you can see there's
a lot of
information there that's lost in that
simple summary
now we do a replication and we do the
same contrast in a different sample
and again we get the same conclusion the
anterior
is activated wow this is a direct
replication
but if you look at the pattern what's
the signal distribution
it doesn't look so clear that it's
actually a replication
and so difficulty what we do is we'll
pick a coordinate from each of those
and we'll report that coordinate we say
oh we replicated it
but how close did that coordinate have
to be how similar does it have to be
from one study to the next
to count as a replication right those
coordinates are really arbitrary
in this case here there are no voxels
above threshold in common so if you look
at the same voxels they're not
there's not a replication the peaks are
four centimeters apart
you know and for reference the amygdala
is only a centimeter and a half big or
something so four centimeters
is a huge distance in the brain and if
you look at the patterns of activity
those patterns are uncorrelated
so what uh juani and his team did was
look at 135 studies that claim
replication and most of those studies
don't provide enough information to
actually assess replication
they just sort of talk about the same
brain regions of those that do
the average spatial distance between the
original and the replicated peaks
is you know over two centimeters so it's
also very
uh very high um and so this is a real
problem because it's going to prevent us
from aggregating results
and what i'm trying to convince you up
here is that this idea of picking the
peak coordinate and then
you know comparing it or trying to
replicate that sort of general area
is essentially bankrupt um it's just too
imprecise another well-known study that
came out um which is also sort of
uh quite critical um was was by militant
benign and a group of people called the
narps
study and what they did is essentially
generated a prediction market and had a
number of teams
test specific set of hypotheses uh
about a task and which the hypotheses
what they are is not so important here
um but the main thing that you can see
is that
uh these different teams analyze the
same data
and they concluded different things
right the decisions they made about
these hypotheses yes or no
are in many cases not very consistent
um so 70 independent teams chose 70
different pipelines
and so that was sort of one of the
taglines of this paper but if we just
look a little bit deeper
there's actually more interesting stuff
going on
now this figure from the paper shows the
correlations between the spatial maps
and the reds are positive correlation so
that's good and the the entries are
teams
and the reds and greens are hypotheses
which are sort of varying right
but even though the the the threshold
that yes or no decisions vary
the actual maps are very similar for a
large proportion of the teams
so the patterns that there that the
different groups are seeing
are highly correlated except for this
little
bit over here where they think they
conclude that some people kind of did
the analysis wrong or made some mistakes
right so there's another cluster on
okay so the patterns are actually much
more stable
than this decision where you apply a
very stringent threshold and you look at
the tiny peaks that survive you go
how similar are those right so that's
not very stable but the pattern's on
um okay and i'll show you more examples
too of effect size and reliability
but now i'm going to go to the thread
and one more thing here with another
which is this idea that
every brain area has diverse populations
of neurons in it so when we measure a
voxel
we're measuring something that is
heterogeneous there are many different
populations
and there's a very strong literature and
so you see some of the papers here
that's arguing that that those
individual neurons and by extension
individual voxels
are not how information is encoded or
represented in the brain
in fact what's a key for representing
information
is the pattern across the neurons and
across specific
ensembles of neurons within each region
so our job in imaging should be to
identify brain signals that track those
ensembles
the track specific ensembles and test
whether they're tracking
information about one kind of a set of
ensembles or one population code
or another one and that's what i think
this model building approach that we've
been talking about is
is doing um so
uh from this review which i i really
like uh ava becca
and boujee they say is it any good
democracy individual neurons count for
little
it's population activity that matters um
so
highly relevant in u.s politics at this
moment in time today
um so what are the principles well cells
with different functions are intermixed
in local areas
individual neurons are often noisy and
they're not closely linked to behavior
uh and even when they are
um many studies demonstrate that it's
actually the pattern across
all the neurons not just the sort of
most responsive or most selective ones
that's important and the kinds of
psychological functions like pain or
sadness or anger or
working memory performance all of these
things or sustained detention
are not implemented in isolated brain
regions they're implemented in circuits
and those circuits involve specific
ensembles in local areas and they span
multiple areas of the brain so we have
to characterize the circuit
and here are just some examples from
the neuroscience which is generating
amazing uh data
right now amazing revolution in what we
understand about circuits
um and here these are all examples where
you can
tag genetically tag and stimulate a
particular
ensemble of neurons and when you tag
that ensemble
then you get different behaviors
so in this in this study for example um
you you know what they're tagging is an
ensemble related to encoding
uh encoding um a fear memory and they
can reactivate it and then
reproduce the behavior but it's a very
specific ensemble
okay um
all right so now i'm going to move on to
thinking
more about what are the properties and
benefits of these models and i want to
introduce this section by
making the following claim
that i hope you might find controversial
which is that the kinds of predictive
models that i showed you
can serve goals of both prediction and
inference
uh and therefore they're really a way
forward
for many of the answers in neuroscience
that we want so this is a tale of two
doctors
and these two doctors are going to look
at the same brain pattern but
i want different things out of it same
brain model so dr
a is a translational neuroscientist and
she wants to
study the brain to develop biomarkers
for human disease and
and um and you know why do we need those
she wants mechanistic targets for what's
happening in the brain as she's doing
treatments or testing treatments
dr b is a basic scientist and he says i
just want to understand the brain
[Music]
i just want to understand the brain
representation how it codes information
so dr a is interested in biomarkers
which are physiological objectively
measured processes
that indicate some mental experience and
why she's interested in them
is because the hidden causes of diseases
and mental health disorders that she's
interested in
are hidden they are not directly
observable
take pain for example we can't see pain
we often can't trust other indicators
and in many cases we the pain doesn't
exist yet it's
it's a predisposition so if you're going
to develop a prognostic biomarker right
you need to know
who's going to who's going to get pain
later or a predictive biomarker who's
going to respond to a treatment that you
can't see
um so these are really hidden mechanisms
and the main value of of this
uh brain imaging i think in this case is
to develop
those uh uh systems models not to
recapitulate pain
but as mechanistic targets for diagnosis
and intervention
so for example is this baby in pain well
we don't know we can't observe the pain
we can only see the behavior and of
course babies can't tell us
this is a high stakes question because
in fact even today
babies uh get painful procedures because
it's commonly assumed that they don't
feel pain the same way that adults do
there's a long
history of that but there's excellent
work in neuroscience from
mariah fitzgerald rebecca slater and
others uh simon begs that really um
suggest that
that they really do show all the neural
and behavioral characteristics of being
in pain
now if you take a step back for a second
you know how would we know what are the
underlying mechanisms driving the pain
well for thousands of years uh uh
theories like this one persistent that
there's you know four kinds of humors
yellow bile black bile blood and phlegm
and they mix in different ways right so
this this affords a whole sort of one
whole set of treatments based on what
you think the underlying causal
mechanism is
and of course in modern scientific view
we don't think that's true anymore
but what is it in the brain that's
that's that's in the body and the
property that's creating
okay let's turn back to dr b now so dr b
is interested in representations a
representation i'll define here a brain
representation as
a causal obligatory physical basis for a
mental experience
or information processing structure so
it's something where
if you can activate it in the brain you
always get
pain let's say uh and if you turn it off
you never get pain
um so uh dr lee might be interested in
this question
well what's the representation of pain
and there have been uh a number of
claims that have gotten a lot of
attention that when you observe other
people in pain
that activates a shared sensory
representation it activates your pain
system
and that helps you empathize so dr b
wants to know
is that is that the case are there
shared representations
and so i will suggest to you that there
is
really common ground between prediction
and explanation although there
are distinct goals if you think about
them uh the intersection is really
important so what is prediction without
explanation well it's a black box
in a black box you don't know when you
can trust it when is it being unfair
what's driving its behavior so it's not
uh very useful and there's a big debate
now about
interpretability in all kinds of machine
learning models
and if you have explanation without
prediction
it is just a story it's an unfalsifiable
explanation because it doesn't make any
strong predictions
and so you don't know if that
explanation is right or if it's useful
or if it's true so
in the intersection is explanation
that's supported by testable falsifiable
predictions
so both dr a and dr b here are really
trying to
measure brain signals related to an
underlying construct
it could be pain or anger or stress or
intelligence
or memory etc
and if they're measuring contracts
there's a common set of empirical
criteria
that we ought to be interested in and
those
are whether the model is testable
in new individuals whether it's
sensitive and specific to the construct
that you're trying to measure
uh so if pain is a construct you know it
should a specific
sensitive means it responds when it is
pain specific means it doesn't respond
when it's not pain
it ought to be robust generalizable
across different types or instances of
pain
it ought to be interpretable in terms of
the circuits and other literature and
converging evidence from neuroscience
and we ought to be able to actually use
it um okay
and and test it across labs so
dr a might be interested in you know if
you have a generalizable model for pain
the claim is that it's going to respond
across multiple types thermal mechanical
visceral
and so dr a says what is this thing
really measuring right we don't know is
it tracking all kinds of pain is it
tracking only pain
and dr b might say well which parts of
the brain are important what are they
what's the key brain representation is
that shared across
uh uh social pain or um
or observing other people in pain as
well
so let's look at generalizability for a
second
uh there's this idea that there are
gradients of generalization of multiple
kinds so for any brain model you know
you might be interested in
what it tracks uh is it only a very
specifics in this
condition one type of pain in one spot
um
is it a class of similar states is it
very diverse exemplars of all kinds of
of examples of the contract um
you might be interested in which
populations who in whom
is this model only applicable to one
person
in you know in one sort of moment and
that's what most of the mdpa or
predictive models on
from vision for example and other areas
are designed to do
they're only supposed to apply to one
person but all the models i'll show you
are designed to generalize
to other groups of people maybe new
individuals from the same sample or
population
maybe multiple samples of different
characteristics or maybe even
heterogeneous populations
and you might be interested in in which
contexts
does this model predict the outcome
that's intended to break let's say pain
you know a very narrow context with the
exact same cognitive and stimulus
conditions
a similar context or a very very broad
set of contexts is it robust across many
of them
so we can test if we have a model we can
apply to new individuals in new studies
which we do
we can test this in various ways so this
is just one example of that same pain
signature
being tested on a data set with
20 different studies from around the
world to 600 people
so there are relatively diverse
populations uh at least compared to most
studies
and it's diverse in terms of the types
of pain that's being assessed
electrical heat laser mechanical
visceral which is actually a rectal
balloon
in this case so multiple types of evoked
pain
and what you see here is each of the
rows is one of the studies
or the 20 studies and a shift to the
right
means the study is the response the nps
the pain signatures responding to pain
and the small dots are individual
participants
so you can see all the individual
participants and what you can see is
is that it responds in the right
direction for the vast majority of
participants
95 and the effect side is
massive uh uh for reference russ
poldrick published a really nice paper
called scanning the horizon in 2017 and
the broad claim
for our purposes is that if you look in
areas where you see a real signal you
know there's a real signal and you're
measuring how big it is but it's an
isolated area
effect size about 0.5 which is moderate
effect size
um moderate reproducibility
and power um and here the effect size is
much much larger so you can really see
this in individual people
let's take a look at specificity i'm
going to go back to this idea about
observed pain
and self pain experience pain uh and it
really does matter
so one of my favorite sort of foils here
david brooks although
like many of the things he's written he
wrote this article called the
archipelago of pain
and what it claimed is that
self pain physical pain and looking and
um
and um looking at other people in pain
or
um or experiencing social pain
are all look the same in the brain and
because they all look the same in the
brain
then we really ought to uh treat
emotional distress
differently when it comes to policy
um and indeed you know um
you know yeah she'll be treating
emotional harm like physical harm then
right
and and indeed uh there are published
papers
and a lot of data suggesting that at the
sort of overall level
um these things really do look similar
they all activate the anterior cingulate
cortex they activate the anterior cortex
um so here's a pattern based study so
what are the what are the population
codes show us
well here we have somatic pain and
vicarious pain so looking at other
people in pain and
we have two locations for each arm and
foot and we have three
pre-selected intensities designed to
create a variation in the range of
of somatic pain and a variation in the
range of vicarious pain so how bad is it
and what we can see is these are the
pain ratings that they're
matched across both there's really a
nice distribution that's similar in pain
ratings
and people think both of these things
are bad somatic pain vicarious pain
okay so now we can ask what happens with
our
pain signature does it respond to
vicarious pain
the answer is no it doesn't it
tracks pain when it's self pain those
are the warm colors
across two body sites it doesn't mean we
can't discriminate body sites too
but this pattern works for both body
sites to a large degree
it so it's a really nice dose response
function but there's no response
to looking at somebody else's pain so at
the pattern level
this is quite different and in this
paper we demonstrate this in many many
ways essentially beyond what i'm showing
you here
and we can take the same data and we can
ask is there a signature in the brain or
a pattern
that tracks vicarious pain the intensity
of vicarious pain
again all these are new individual
subjects so they're all sort of unbiased
um
tests that you're seeing here in the
graphs
and the answer is yes and it generalizes
across hand and foot
and map stimulus intensity very nicely
but there's no response to self paint
so this pattern is called separate
modifiability it's one of the strongest
criteria that i know of the process
separately
we've got two patterns that respond to
two things we can do this across the
brain
we can do this with individualized
patterns we can do it with
selected areas of the brain that are
supposed to respond in common like the
anterior cingulate cortex
and we get the same answer we can also
replicate this
with different paradigms so here's
another study where
uh women came into the scanner and their
male partner was
outside the scanner so they experienced
uh pain for themselves and they were
watching their partner's arm
through a mirror which is always present
so the visual stimulation is constant
but then they were cute that their
partner was going to experience pain
and so there were some periods where
they knew that their partner was getting
pain
even though there was no visual cues and
we can look at the neurologic pain
signature for soft pain vicarious pain
signature
and we again see this separate
modifiability process
so and you can see the individual
subjects here as well as the the bar
graph in the group
the nps responds only to self pain
not to pain on the other but the
vicarious pain signature
responds only to pain on the other not
to pain on the cell
so it replicates that pattern in the new
study
and the thing about specificity is
that it's an open-ended process you can
always think of something that
maybe that looks like pain but it's not
pain right
maybe it's breathlessness or maybe it's
something else or maybe it sounds or
maybe it's some you know
you can keep going which is great but we
have to of course
test that across study so it's an
open-ended process so we can
assess specificity as well as
generalizability on new cohorts
and so for this demonstration i'm going
to show you a data set
that that phil cragal collected together
for multiple studies
and here there's 270 participants
and a third of them get pain and the
pain is divided up into three types of
pain
thermal visceral mechanical and there's
two studies
of each type of pain and 15 subjects
and there's three studies of cognitive
control working memory response
selection response competition
two studies of each 15 subjects and
there's uh three types of negative
emotion
from pictures from social cues and from
auditory cue
sounds uh and two studies of each type
so it's a systematically sampled set and
the point of phil's paper i'm not going
to tell you about in this talk but i
encourage you to read it if you're
interested in generalizability
because the point is that you can
identify generalizable representations
using this systematic set
that are not shared across across other
domains
and you can test their generalizability
but for now i'm going to stick with the
pain signature i'm just going to show
you
the nps responses across all of these
data sets
and again the dots are individual
subjects the vars or studies
so you can see that there's a threshold
at which uh
almost all of the pain subjects respond
um and in very few of the other
conditions maybe one of the auditory
studies there you know um uh
most of the studies they don't respond
um
you know the nba or i should say the nps
does not respond
right um you can try all these things
yourself by the way so we built a whole
system of tools if you're interested in
this and
you can use our k-lab code tools on
canva.github.io and you can
you can try this you know with two lines
of code
and reproduce it so overall
we've been actively sharing uh data and
models with people across
laboratories and it's been really fun
because i've sort of gone around and
given talks and say
well maybe you have something that looks
like pain but it isn't pain it's an
interesting test case
so let's test it out and by sharing
these data across these different
cohorts
we've been able to characterize what
this thing this measure
responds to and what it doesn't respond
to of course there's more to go but this
is a snapshot so far
it does respond to multiple types of
above pain and to some degree
things like are somatic distress like
breathlessness
aversive taste and painful sounds
although they don't seem to track with
the intensity
they don't track the intensity in the
same way and it doesn't respond to
a number of tests uh and some of which
we've discussed you know um
aversive images arousing salient
horrible things
looking at um the person who rejected
use of social rejection cues
looking at other people in pain
anticipating pain and other conditions
including some somatic ones potentially
um okay so now uh there's this idea
that when you have gone through this
process and validated
a model in all these ways the more you
know about the model
the more useful it is and then testing
interesting test cases
and making some influences about the
mind so this is where these hard one
instances about the mind come in at the
end
right of this process and so you can ask
is this baby in pain well again
we never know because we can't observe
that baby's internal
state um but what we can do
is apply the nps as a validated measure
to infant data after appropriately
normalizing them so eugene duff put a
lot of work into trying to match the
the brains and apply the signature and
what you can see here
is an invalidation adults it responds
this is a the sort of um propane
nociceptive
uh part of the nps it's it's responding
you know in adults
um there's an anti-pain system part
which is this
sort of a default mode and visual cortex
and things that are deactivated with
pain
it does not activate and so that's a
validation
that that the system is working in this
study for adults across stimulus
intensities
and then applying it to two studies in
infants where again that propane nps
is increasing across stimulus
intensities
so infants are encoding that and that's
one piece of the puzzle among others
that suggests that
that yes infants have very similar
neurological responses to pain as well
as
similar kinds of behaviors
okay so um i'll drop talk a little bit
about interpretability and model sharing
before i wrap up
so interpretability is really important
and we've been thinking a lot about how
to do this and so i want to point you to
this
uh paper that came out recently this is
from wani wu's group
i'm carrying on a sort of
elaborate and detailed program of
research
and in this paper we really thought
about different
kinds of ways of interpreting and
validating models
uh and so there's a feature level
assessment which is
some human readable representation of
what which voxels
or which features contribute to that
pattern so how do you reconstruct a
sensible
map and there's a model level assessment
asking things like does this track
compounds or is it independent of
compound
could be head movement um and many
others right
um you know is it generalizable
et cetera and biology level assessment
which is um you know which means that
you have to
take the the features of the model and
interpret them in relation to past
literature and animal studies
so do you get sensible um pathways that
match
what you'd see in animals and can
validate externally
i think all those things are really
important um
okay so then you know we can
uh develop experiments and there's this
whole progress i'm not gonna walk you
through all of this but there's a whole
process that um that we outlined in this
paper
of developing provisional models and
then doing
a lot of the hard work to say does it
does it perform well
um is it independent of compounds like
head movement or
medication usage or something like that
if it's a clinical
and that involves testing in new data uh
and then
uh and starting to interpret the model
features do they make sense
are they in the brain are they in places
where we can validate them are they
stable and reproducible features
uh and then is the model generalizable
is it biologically plausible you know so
some award-winning models in the brain
have turned out to
uh to track activity in the ventricles
where there's no real signal so that
their problem or track
head movement essentially in fancy ways
right
and if we fail these tests we have to
sort of go back and and re-engineer
better models
um and then we can start to understand
you know
how it performs on new data more broadly
um
and so forth so this is some simple
ideas uh we can take these
resting state networks it's just one way
of characterizing um
any of these models right and we can
break them down into the loadings on
these large scale networks
so here's a signature that tracks
emotional experience and you can see
which networks it loads positively on
ventral attention and visual networks
um and inside the circle by the way
there's negative correlations with photo
parietal
dorsal attention sonata motor networks
but if you look at our our uh pain
signature
that's what we've been talking about the
nps it loads positively on ventral
attention to many motor networks a very
different pattern
if you look at the vicarious pain
signature it also shows
a very distinct pattern of network
loadings so they're really different
large-scale systems that we're tracking
and here's some code if you're
interested in that
another kind of interpretation is we can
we can ask how much of the brain and in
which systems do you need to accurately
make a prediction about pain
or about emotion or whatever your
outcome is
and so um in this demonstration
uh um we have a comparison between
the best single region which is way down
here it doesn't work very well
at predicting pain um and
the whole brain model is way up here at
the top end
and what you can see is a single region
doesn't do very well
as you add voxels that's you're moving
to the right you end up
getting more and more accurate um and it
levels off here at some point
and and these lines are when you run the
prediction with only
the an individual network only the
sonata motor network for only the
voxels in the eventual retention network
and you can see that no model really
does
um as well as the whole brain
and bogdan petrie has a preprint from my
lab that that really
goes further and characterizes this in a
lot of detail i think it's a great paper
but i'm not going to talk about it here
um we can also take a model like this
which is across the brain
and we can break it down into its local
information content
so this is a predictive model from
another study um
that we developed based on several
hundred people and then we can go back
and say well this is a pain predictive
model
well what about what about the thalamus
is is the signal is are the
contributions different in different
parts of the thalamus
and here you see that they are um
actually and this is a beautiful
thalamic atlas by
morel and the morel atlas um
which which they shared with us and you
know you can see here what i put stars
over
is all of the thalamic zones that really
are
known to convey nociceptive and pain
information from the
uh from animal studies and human
invasive studies
um and so you can see that the larger
the wedge there
the the greater the the uh pattern
weight
there the greater the contribution in
the model to paint
and we can break it down into thalamic
regions and other brainstem regions that
are really important in animal models
but that are very seldom discussed in
human models
okay and now i'm just gonna wrap up by
talking about
model sharing and going back to this
idea of the snapshot of translational
neuroscience
well we have a problem here because we
have 500 studies
and we have 500 different models
and we don't really need you know 100
models of
alzheimer's disease and 100 models of
ptsd which are all different and hard to
compare
we have what my old colleague walter
michelle called the toothbrush problem
which is nobody wants to use somebody
else's
[Music]
and in fact in this review we
characterized
the models at the time and there are a
small handful that have gone from
single sample to perspective validation
in a new sample
actually being tested in a brand new
sample unbiased and there's a few models
that are named here you can see this
orchid stands there's some alzheimer's
models um
spare ad is an alzheimer's pdrp is a a
parkinson's disease related pattern
with data by david eidelberg's group and
and so
you know as you march into the more and
more data and more replications across
laboratories there are very few of those
named models
but that's a really important thing and
we have to share models and test them
so to that end we've started sharing all
of our models i got inspired by the idea
of a model zoo
in ai a lot of the deep neural network
models you know for example
are shareable and reusable and it's
great um so we have
we have a website here and a github
repository where we have
shared multiple things all of the
multivariate predictive models
including now the the nps that i showed
you and others
so you can download them and and try
them out for yourself and there's a
there's a growing family of them
meta-analysis masks from meta-analyses
over the years that you can apply to new
studies
brain parcellations and some of these
are from our lab and many of them are
from other labs that uh that agreed to
share these data too
i'd be happy to um to host them as well
because i think the more focal points
for sharing we have
the better so in sum i have talked to
you about
the idea that we need a paradigm shift
from isolated brain maps
to integrated models that predict
outcomes
i've used pain prediction as an example
of how we can
test this model across many conditions
and studies
and share date both data and models and
i've talked about some of its properties
and benefits
including large effect size high
reliability
uh high reproducibility of effects
high specificity to a construct in this
case pain
and high generalizability across
multiple types of evoked pain
and then finally i've talked about the
idea of sharing these models
and working together which is really the
fun part of science
and i'm just going to end by saying
thank you to my current lab members
and my former lab members many of whom
are collaborating
i'm still uh and have contributed a
tremendous amount
and to our funding agencies over the
years
and thank you very much for your
attention torah thank you
so much that is really an impressive
body of work to
try to understand the brain's response
to pain and the role of cognition
emotion um with the goal of trying to
find out what can be generalizable what
can be
explainable and how you can leverage
computational models in order to
give you some insights i i want to
invite our um
our biomedical data science seminar
series
fellows to contribute any questions they
have for dr wager via the zoom chat
feature
and while we're waiting for those to
accumulate um
i wanted to get your your thoughts you
presented a number of different studies
some of which were
kind of mega analyses that is just very
large numbers of subjects that you
actually have the data for and can
reprocess
versus some of the other studies that
you looked at which were meta-analyses
where you're drawing from
what people have reported in the
literature and it when
just in my own experience and perhaps
this is yours as well
the studies which tend to be very
critical are those which
are the meta analytic ones um they
always seem to be
the ones that kind of show everybody
what they're doing wrong
and i'm curious about your comments
about that in the context of reliability
and whether or not
the choices of processing which are
going to be very heterogeneous when
you're doing a meta-analysis of the
literature
are those different from what you're
doing in a very large sample
mega analysis like the uk biobank and if
you have any thoughts on
the distinction there and whether or not
that's an important factor
some of the heterogeneity that we're
seeing yeah you know
think jack um no i think i i spent um
probably 15 years we're still doing i'm
doing doing coordinate-based
meta-analysis so summaries from
published papers
to characterize what's consistent in the
literature i think those things are
really useful and like i said we're
still doing some
but um those coordinate summaries like a
paper and a table is a really
impoverished
sort of picture uh and so we've really
tried to move
i got excited about you know towards
this sort of mega analysis approach
where we're getting
you know the the full image data the
full set of effect sizes because you can
use so much
more with it and ideally even the
individual person level maps because
then you can really test
you know for for individual by
individual how often would we make a
correct prediction
you can look at spatial similarity
across you know brain patterns and
and and data sets um uh and you can you
can test you know
the rough workability across um subjects
and make population inference in that
way
so i i like the meta-analysis we've got
i've become
a real fan of the you know sort of the
integrated data sharing um
mega analysis approach and i think it
can be used to make
very critical points but it can all you
know but it could also just be used to
generate new um
new hypotheses and data and models are
there any dangers
with problems of like publication bias
in meta-analytic assessments
you know we're really people only
publishing those things which are
statistically significant so we're
leaving out
a possible bunch of null results that
could inform some of our
uh meta-analytic statements
yeah no right i think there's lots lots
of issues one that comes to mind that
you sort of highlighted
is you know if let's say you're you're
summarizing uh published
exercises from papers right and every
fear study does a region of interest
analysis then you make them
and they always find it because it's
especially very liberal right
and so what do you do you know do you
include everything that's what we've
sort of done and then you find the amigo
it's really important
but is it really the strongest signal in
the brain related to fear
uh no it's not not even close right and
there's some new work that actually
shows that
or do you leave those out and say we're
not going to publish roi
analyses but then you you've um you've
excluded all the studies where people
tested principle hypotheses
right and now so it's really a hard
problem the idea of bias
bias in sampling bias and selection
going in
is a really difficult problem um if we
share data and we get the full
maps that actually really uh helps i
think in that regard
i have uh we're at the top of the hour
here but i want to ask one more
question there's a bunch of them coming
in which i'm happy to share with you
offline to dr wager but uh because of
time i want to get this last one really
what
what is the role i mean you met you
presented a bunch of work that really
looks like it has a lot of data science
in it there's a lot of
computational modeling you mentioned
machine learning deep learning
support vector machines a number of
different techniques what role do you
think that
card carrying data scientists have to
play
in order to help identify robust and
robot reliable patterns that might be
useful
as biomarkers in things like pain
and the brain yeah i think that data
science is super
important um i mean it's like a
basically essential skill set then to be
able to do these things
um but what i'll also say is is that
what i think the most
successful sort of sweet spot is is
somebody with those
the skills the data science skills the
technical skills the mathematical skills
and computational skills
but also a real interest in the brain in
understanding how to translate the sort
of
technical bits right into what are
people going to understand what does the
field need to know what do we need what
you know
what level can we can we uh frame this
or describe this
to really make it understandable for the
audience which is
which is you know neuroscientists and
psychologists and and
the public so i think there is this sort
of real intersection of
interests right that's going to
characterize very successful uh people
in this area
well with that i want to thank uh dr tor
wager from dartmouth college for a
fantastic
uh tour de force on discussing of uh
how to characterize the brain's response
to pain how to generate models that can
be
both explanatory predictive and useful
um and for sharing them all i think
that's wonderful
and so thank you again dr weger i really
appreciate it i want to thank everybody
who joined us
and uh i want to wish everybody a very
good weekend
uh take care everyone thank you thank
you i'm happy to answer some things over
email too if you um send me the chat and
i can i can respond to so many questions
fantastic we'll do that take care
everybody